hey man I never got a chance to thank
you for stopping
Roy thank you thank you not necessary
and thus not accepted I saw someone
breaking the law and I
interceded okay
um got you something don't want it you
don't know what it is don't want it
won't open it don't need it won't take
it citizens do not accept prizes for
being Cit
it was a little glass display case for
his
bobblehead that would have made us even
I think he saves my life I get him a box
for his death
toy even Steven no don't call me a hero
do you know who the real heroes are the
guys who wake up every morning and go
into their normal jobs and get a
distress call from the commissioner and
take off their glasses and change into
capes and fly around fighting crime
those are the real
heroes okay if you don't want a gift at
least let me buy you a beer or lunch or
something when Han Solo returns to the
Death Star in the Millennium Falcon and
shoots down the Tie fighters and Saves
The Rebel cause do you think he does so
for a free
beer boy I no and why are you so
interested in buying me something Jim
what's your
angle
what's
this certificate of Bravery from the
Scranton Police Department recognizing
outstanding citizenship from a very
brave young man Dwight K shut wow I
guess word got around that's a nice
honor please they hand these out to
little kids look there's a teddy bear in
a policeman's
cap didn't think you'd know
that
I will never say a
word and now we are
[Music]
even
did I ever tell you why I left
Scranton yeah I didn't think I
had
well it was all about
Pam yeah I
mean she was with Roy and uh
I just couldn't take
it I mean I lost it to
I I couldn't
sleep I couldn't concentrate on
anything and then weird stuff like
food had no
taste so my solution was to move
away it was
awful and into something that I wouldn't
wish on my worst
enemy and that includes
you
I let white have his fun today will not
be his day what's that I'm going to tank
the saber store at the presentation to
the board shame though I didn't like
Dwight Robert I'm going to win ha I'm
the gentleman suck it Bravo Dwight very
good shame he said I did like Dwight
he's going to fire him listen to me
listen to me no no no no I know will you
just let me tell you one thing please
yes you may tell me one thing wait do
you want to borrow money listen to me
Robert is going to veto the saber store
Jim come on Dwight he's going to kill
the store M and then I'm pretty sure
he's going to fire you for it wait he's
going to kill the
store and he's going to fire me yes
that's two things D please nice try Jim
your pranks have never worked in the
past and they're not going to work today
okay first of all they've mostly worked
so you know what you might want to get
to the airport it's going to take you a
long time to get through security with
all those beauty products bye Dwight
come
nothing is going to stop me that is the
mark of a great man
Unstoppable Thunder Mifflin Farm Mo all
those things vanish in my rearview
mirror now if you'll excuse me I have a
date with Destiny and from what I hear
she's
a help help oh don't lick my hand God
why is there so much saliva all I had to
do is think about pie and my salivary
did the rest gross what
God my appendix I'm sorry my wound
hasn't healed yet I'm sorry oh man I'm
so sorry I forgot you all right you
okay so the reason I called you in here
is because Andy is moving on
again again and I'm looking for a new
manager and with his performance this
year I have been considering Dwight
am I
crazy not at all it should be
Dwight you
sure you're going to want to invest in a
lot more liability insurance but uh hey
if there's someone who loves paper more
than
Dwight I definitely don't want to meet
that
person Jim I need my assistant to the
regional manager code red okay I don't
have my pocket coach art on me right now
so
now I have an assistant now who can help
you with whatever you need he is lazy so
crack the whip Jim I'm not kidding I
need
you go
ahead okay
um this
is I'll be right
back what do we got
I was thinking of proposing to Esther
today wow congratulations that's a
really big step man she's got a ton of
great qualities she's young she's
beautiful jeans so pure you could lick
them her family admires me and my family
tolerates hers A lot of them are the
same people because we're third cousins
which is great for Bloodlines and isn't
technically incest right in The Sweet
Spot I think you're going to be really
happy plus her dowy contains a walk-in
freezer full of Frozen premium cattle
sperm that's a lot of and did I mention
that she weaves colorful durable
blankets and rugs it all adds up so what
is the
problem
Angela I don't know what you want me to
tell you
man all I know is that every time I've
been faced with a tough
decision there's only one thing that
that way is every other
concern one thing that will make you
give up on everything you thought you
knew every
Instinct every rational
calculation some sort of
virus
love listen no matter what
happens you got to forget about all the
other stuff you got to forget about
logic and fear and doubt you just got to
do everything you can to get to the one
woman who's going to make all this worth
it at the end of the
day you got to
[Music]
jump you love Angela
Dwight I think you always
have you're a good assistant
Jim not a good to
you that's very
true get the hell out of here you got
it you kidding I was born
[Music]
ready
um I don't know how to tell you this but
we have a little bit of a problem no
what the minister just told me that it's
tradition for the bestiest mench to be
older than the groom
oh come on I've never heard of such a
thing I haven't heard of it obviously
but I'm out because I'm significantly
younger than you not significant as a
big word I think well okay either way
either way
Dwight I can't be there for
you I'm
sorry Jim I just really wish there was
something I could
do
Michael I can't believe you came that's
what she
[Laughter]
said best prank
ever